بعد ايام من تعيينه وزيرا بنغفير يقتحم
الاقصى وسطى ادانه واسعه التحقيقات تنفي
وجود شبه جنائيه بوفاه زوج البرجر المصريه
اقبال ضخم على حفل تقديم نادي النصر
للاعبه الجديد رونالدو هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد ايام من توليه منصب وزير الامن القومي
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهو المنصب الذي
يمنحه سلطات على الشرطه اقتحمى اثمار بن
خفير باحات المسجد الاقصى وسطه ادانت
عربيه واسعه الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
معربه في بيان عن اسفي المملكه لما تقوم
به اسرائيل الاخيره من ممارسات تقويض جهود
السلام الدوليه وتتعارض مع المبادئ
والاعراف الدوليه في احترام المقدسات
الدينيه كما دانت مصر والاردن والامارات
والكويت وقطر وجامعه الدول العربيه
واسطه حالنا من الحزن في مدينه الاسكندريه
تم تشييع جثمان المخرج المصري محمد تيفا
زوج البلوجر مريم جودا الذي توفي بشكل
مفاجئ بعد ساعه قليله من الاحتفال براس
السنه مع زوجته وعقب الجدل الذي اسير في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه حول وجود شبه
جنائيه في وفاه فيفا كشفت التحقيقات
الاوليه انه بعد مناظره جثمانه تبين عدم
وجود ايه اصابات ظاهريه في جسد متوفى
والتاكيد على ان الوفاه جاءت طبيعيه
لتصدر جهات تحقيق المعنيه قرارها بالتصريح
بدفن الجبهه
وسط حضور الجماهيريه نظم نادي النصر
السعودي حفلا كبيرا لتقديم لاعبه الجديد
كريستيانو رونالدو في ملعب مرصول بارك
بالعاصمه الرياض رونالدو قال في المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي سبق بدءا انطلاق الحفل انه
يفتخر باتخاد قرار الانضمام الى نادي
النصر رغم العروض الاوروبيه التي قدمت له
مضيفا انه يسعى الى تحطيم الارقام
القياسيه مع النادي السعودي وقبل هذا
الحدث الكبير بساعات شهد الموقع الخاص
لبيع التذاكر اقبالا كبيرا اذ وصل في
الطوابير والالكترونيه الخاصه بالموقع
لاكثر من 130,000 شخص يبحثون عن التذكره
لمشاهده نجم مصر الجديده كريستيانو
رونالدو في اخبار عالم الرياضه ايضا تصدرت
صوره تجمع النجمين المغربي اشرف حكيمي
والفرنسيه
في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الصوره التي
نصرها حكيمي عبر حسابه الرسمي على تويتر
يظهر فيها ثنائي باريس سان جيرمان
تعطى في دوري السله الامريكيه لتنهل
التعليقات عليها وسط اشاده بعلاقه الصداقه
التي تربطهما في مكان كريستوف غلتيه مدرب
نادي الباريسيه قد قرر اراحه من باقي
وحكيم بعد مشاركته ثنائي في مبارتين
بالدوري الفرنسي ضد ستراسبورغ ولانس اذ
انهما لم يحصل على الراحه بعد انتهاء
مشوار منتخبهما في كاس العالم
وفي خبرنا الاخير حضر مدير وكاله ناسا بيل
نيلسون من ان السباق الى القمر بين امريكا
والصين اصبحت تنافسيا بشكل متزايد بلوى من
الممكن ان يحسم العامين المقبلان من الذي
سيفوز في هذا السباق ووفقا لصحيفه بولتيكو
الامريكيه فقد توقع ان السنه انه في حال
انتصار الصين في هذا السباق فان ذلك قد
يؤدي الى مطالبتها بملكيه مساحات شاسعه من
القمر تضم اكثر المناطق ثراء بالموارد
فيما كانت الحكومه الصينيه وحددت الشهر
الماضي خطوطها لمزيدا من المشاريع الطموحه
كالتطوير البنيه التحتيه للفضاء وانشائي
نظام اداره الفضاء
[موسيقى]